wir brauchen mehr Waffen diese
Forderungen musste auch von der Leyen
mehrfach heute hören und wir haben
exklusiv auch mit Vladimir Klitschko
über den hinterhältigen Angriff auf den
flüchtlingsbahnhof gesprochen er fordert
eindringlich Konsequenzen auch von
deutscher Seite
es ist gut dass
hochrangierte Politiker anreisen in die
Ukraine nach Kiew um es selbst in den
Augen zu sehen wie die Lage ist weil
letztendlich wir verteidigen hier nicht
nur die Ukraine wird verteidigen auch
unsere demokratische Werte weil wenn wir
fallen dann fällt die westliche Welt
auch und der erste Welt auch das waren
tausende mehrere tausend am Bahnhof in
kramerdorf und genau da dorthin haben
die russische Streitkräfte gezielt es
ist präzise Exekution
[Musik]
Bevölkerungs in der Ukraine präzise
russische Armee hat genau gewusst dass
in die Flüchtlinge
die gesammelt haben tausende davon die
auf dem weg waren und auf ihre Züge
gewartet haben um in die Sicherheit zu
kommen und dorthin
gezielt ein Rakete abzuschießen und die
Menschen töten das ist Wiederholungen
von
Daten die vor kurzen über der Bianca
gestorben
gemacht worden im Süden der Ukraine
mariopel leidet nach wie vor
es ist die Gefühle sind nicht zu
beschreiben diese sinnlose Krieg muss
beendet werden
ich verstehe dass Europa Deutschland
konkret sehr abhängig von dem russischen
Gas und Öl ist ist aber machbar
in diese Zeiten wo wir zahlen mit dem
Leben unsere Bürger
von allen Gas
russischen
wird nicht aufhören wenn wir nicht diese
Aggression stoppen ich habe schon vor
kurzem genannt was dafür notwendig ist
ich wiederhole es noch einmal im Bahnhof
von Ölen Gast es ist ganz wichtig auch
die Waffenlieferung für unsere
ukrainische Armee wir brauchen keine
andere Armee auf dem ukrainischen Boden
wie schaffen das selbst wir müssen uns
verteidigen weil das internationale
Recht ist gebrochen worden in Europa der
Zweiten Weltkrieg in Europa in eine der
großen Länder Europas die Ukraine mit
russischen Invasion werden unsere
Zivilisten unsere Bevölkerung vernichtet
wenn eine Land das andere Land
angegriffen hat und Leute haben ihre so
wie wir in der Ukraine haben unsere
Zuhause verloren Familienmitglieder
verloren Familien komplett verloren wir
sind viele viele viele Kinder umgebracht
wurden
du hast keine andere Wahl als sich nur
zu verteidigen unsere Wille ist enorm
und diese Wille wird enormen Widerstand
für diese Aggression die aus Russland
kam
diese Wille wird uns auch zum Sieg
führen und unsere Partner unsere
Weggefährten auf die wir uns auch führen
lassen müssen weil allein wahrscheinlich
werden es nicht schaffen deswegen
brauchen wir enorm diese Unterstützung
von unserem Weggefährten unseren
Partnern seit 2014 kämpfen wir für diese
Freiheit stehen wir für diese Freiheit
für die demokratische Werte die wir
teilen auch mit der europäische Freiwild
wir müssen es schaffen wir haben keine
andere Wahl und das werden wir schaffen
mit Unterstützung gemeinsam wenn wir das
Recht bekommen um gewinnen diesen
sinnlosen Krieg verteidigen uns und
unsere Recht im Freien Europa zu leben
es betrifft nicht nur die Ukraine es
betrifft jeden in Europa weil diese
Regression wird weiter rollen das haben
die schon angekündigt die
diese russische Propaganda hat schon das
angekündigt dass die weitere Rollen und
Ukraine ist nur der Anfang vergessen Sie
nicht über die Zeiten der DDR
um die Mauer vergessen Sie nicht es kann
wieder zurückkommen das wollen wir nicht
deswegen müssen wir hier in der Ukraine
ein Stopp geben